bien mes chers collègues nous allons
continuer notre réunion nous
accueillons monsieur gundram Wolf
bonjour bonjour monsieur je pense que
vous nous entendez bien je vous vois au
piné du chef désolé de ce petit retard
mais nous recevions l'ambassadeur
espagnol sur la première moitié de la de
la Réunion et voilà ça c'est prolongé un
petit peu puisqu'il y a des projets
importants de gazoduc et il fallait que
qu'on puisse qu'on puisse en parler donc
Monsieur le Directeur mes chers
collègues nous sommes très
reconnaissants à Monsieur Guntram Wolf
d'avoir accepté notre invitation à
s'exprimer ce matin devant notre
commission pour nous livrer son analyse
vu de Berlin sur l'évolution récente de
la relation franco-allemande Monsieur le
Directeur vous avez jusqu'à l'été
dernier dirigé le signe Tang Bruegel et
vous avez aussi été membre du Conseil
d'analyse économique vous avez donc
acquis une expertise reconnue des enjeux
économiques aussi bien à l'échelle
européenne qu'à l'échelle française ce
qui sera précieux pour répondre à les
interrogations notamment sur la
conséquence de la flambée des prix de
l'énergie et nous vous remercions très
sincèrement d'avoir accepté de le faire
en français ce qui facilitera nos
échanges le récent report du Conseil des
ministres franco-allemand a été
interprété à Paris comme la
manifestation d'une crise de confiance
entre la France et l'Allemagne qu'on
lisait déjà en filigrane dans
l'incapacité ou semble se trouver le
Conseil européen à convenir d'une
solution solidaire pour sortir de la
crise énergétique la rencontre qui a
suivi entre le chancelier Scholl c'est
le président Macron à Paris mercredi
dernier a été présenté comme
constructive mais l'absence de
déclaration commune à la presse à son
issue assemblée dire le contraire
quel est selon vous la profondeur de la
crise actuelle de la relation entre la
France et l'Allemagne crise qui semble
d'ailleurs faire plus de vagues à Paris
qu'à Berlin ces tensions récentes vous
paraissent-elles plus préoccupante que
celle surmontée avec succès par le passé
comment mai 2020 quand l'Allemagne et la
France ont parvenus à proposer ensemble
de lancer un emprunt mutualisé pour
relancer l'Europe après la pandémie j'ai
hier encore interrogé le gouvernement à
ce sujet dans l'hémicycle à l'occasion
des questions d'actualité il n'est pas
nouveau que l'Allemagne mette la France
devant le fait accompli et l'a déjà fait
pour des décisions structurantes pour
l'Europe par exemple en matière
énergétique
je pense à sa sortie brutale du
nucléaire après Fukushima ou à son
obstination sur nordstring 2 la guerre
en Ukraine signifie un changement
d'époque et oblige l'Allemagne à des
changements radicaux dans le contexte
inédit d'une coalition gouvernementale
tripartite
mais l'Allemagne continue de jouer
cavalier seul elle sort de son chapeau
200 milliards pour amortir la crise
énergétique elle refuse la demande
française de plafonnement européen du
prix du gaz elle choisit SpaceX plutôt
carian 6 pour lancer ses satellites elle
achète des équipements militaires
américains sans égard pour les projets
franco-allemands de chars et d'avion de
combat et après avoir abandonné le tigre
en particulier
la question du bouclier anthym ici
européen sans la France a été aussi une
question à la fois d'actualité mais mise
en avant
médiatiquement et le chancelier allemand
se rend à Pékin à qui le port d'Hambourg
est vendu en partie donc cette question
aussi pour nous est préoccupante bref
nous avons le sentiment que la confiance
est rompue tout au moins en berne entre
l'Allemagne et la France après guerre la
construction européenne s'était faite
grâce à la convergence d'intérêts entre
une Allemagne qui cherchait la
rédemption et une France qui voulait
réincarner sa puissance ceci c'était
après guerre les générations ont changé
et aujourd'hui l'Allemagne ne s'excuse
plus elle s'affirme et la France semble
en particulier à sa remorque
déjà distancé en matière économique
notre pays risque à présent le
déclassement diplomatique
l'élargissement qui s'annonce à l'Est
ramène l'Allemagne encore plus au centre
de l'Europe
ce qui a manifesté le discours que le
chancelier Scholl sa prononcé à Prague
fin août c'est pourquoi nous nous
interrogeons l'Allemagne est-elle
capable de mieux articuler ces intérêts
propres avec l'intérêt stratégique
supérieur que nos deux pays partagent
c'est à dire et je concluais comme ça
hier une Europe de paix et de liberté
plus précisément peut-on s'entendre sur
une vision commune de l'autonomie
stratégique quand l'Allemagne ne semble
pas prête à payer le prix de la
solidarité européenne notamment en
matière énergétique ou de la préférence
communautaire en matière spatiale ou
d'armement et quand elle ne consent pas
à l'exportation d'armement qu'à titre
exceptionnel en soutien à l'Ukraine en
vous souhaitant la bienvenue au Sénat je
vous cède donc la parole
et ensuite nous nous prendrons les
questions de nos collègues s'ils en ont
en tout cas merci Monsieur le Directeur
d'avoir
accepté notre invitation qui s'est faite
un peu tardive mais l'actualité s'est en
accéléré vous comprenez que il fallait
que nous puissions vous entendre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président je
tiens à remercier le Sénat pour cet
invitation et un grand merci pour déjà
cette introduction très claire et très
dure qui me met dans une position
difficile je suis je suis à Berlin que
depuis quelques mois
et comme vous l'aviez dit j'ai travaillé
intensivement sur les thèmes de la
coopération européenne au cours des 14
dernières années et justement aussi
beaucoup avec des amis j'ai travaillé
beaucoup avec des amis et collègues à
Paris
je regrette d'autant plus les tensions
actuelles entre la France et l'Allemagne
et
évidemment en tant que académique
indépendant je ne suis pas toujours
d'accord
avec les décisions prises au sein du
gouvernement allemand
il y a des raisons de fond sur les
tensions actuelles mais aussi des
raisons personnelles et atmosphériques
et
je dirais dans mon rôle en tant que
académique indépendant
je vais plutôt me focaliser sur les
raisons de fond et moi sur les questions
du personnel et
de la chimie personnelle entre
les politiciens
à mon avis il nous faut d'abord
parvenir à une compréhension
des des principaux défis une
compréhension stratégique fondamentale
sur nos principaux défis et vu de Berlin
il me semble et vu de l'Europe en fait
il me semble que la guerre russe contre
l'Ukraine et le principal défi pour
l'architecture de la sécurité européenne
l'Union européenne devrait avoir un
intérêt primaire à ce que l'Ukraine
gagne et à ce que la Russie perdent
cette guerre
pour cela
l'Ukraine a besoin d'armes et d'une
soutien financier
ni l'Allemagne ni la France nous
fournissent en quantité suffisante si on
regarde les statistiques par exemple
rassembler par l'Institut
à qui en Allemagne et l'Institut
d'économie mondiale à qui elle
le soutien français et clairement
suffisant par rapport à son produit
intérieur brut mais le soutien allemand
et également
insuffisant
et si on regarde les statistiques par
rapport aux armes fournies à la à
l'Ukraine en fait l'Allemagne
configure en cinquième ou sixième place
ou par rapport
si on veut comparer l'Allemagne par
exemple avec l'Estonie on fournit
seulement le double que l'Estonie est un
tiers de la Pologne et beaucoup moins
que les Américains et les Britanniques
donc c'est quand même une situation où
à mon avis nous donc nos deux pays
devraient livrer plus des armements et
plus
des
du soutien financier si on parle du
soutien financier
l'Ukraine a besoin de 35 milliards
d'euros
pour couvrir son déficit budgétaire
l'année prochaine
cette somme actuellement n'est pas
disponible n'est pas n'est pas prêt
on ne peut pas attendre que les
États-Unis vont fournir certifie
européen tout d'abord car c'est quand
même notre sécurité qui ont risque
actuellement
la guerre constitue une épreuve
considérable pour les relations Francois
allemandes du point de vue français
peut-être la situation sécuritaire en
Europe de l'Est et peut-être encore
moins central que pour la même manière
mais un rappel s'impose
il y a encore 30 ans
des soldats de l'Union soviétique était
à Berlin
quelques kilomètres ou je suis
actuellement
et
maintes et ces soldats maintenant
maintenant
l'état de non droit de la RDA de la
République démocratique d'Allemagne et
de l'Est
Poutine lui-même était en RDA et avait
pour mission de voler des technologies
et des soutenir la Stasi en tant que
officier du KGB
ajouter une remarque personnelle
[Musique]
ma mère a fui la RDA en 1960 nous savons
donc même dans notre famille comment le
blog soviétique au prix et Bafou des
personnes les personnes et les libertés
fondamentales
donc à mon avis c'est quand même crucial
et central
de prendre ce défi sérieux et pas à la
légère et fournir ce qu'il faut à
l'Ukraine
ni la France on prie au sérieux les
avertissements de nos partenaires de
l'Europe de l'Est concernant la guerre
il y a désormais une nouvelle
orientation à prendre sur ce thème et la
manière et la France doivent coopérer
intensivement à cet égard
cela ne doit pas signifier que nous
renonçons à nos principes libres
fondamentales fondamentaux au contraire
nous devons continuer à insister sur
l'état des droits en Pologne
en Hongrie et d'autres pays mais dans la
domaine de la sécurité et de la défense
nous devons prendre la menace russe au
sérieux sinon vous risquons de créer une
nouvelle division en Europe entre
l'Europe de l'est de la Pologne
[Musique]
de la Slovaquie et d'autres pays et les
pays poétiques et
l'Europe de l'Ouest
donc premier grand thème c'est la
politique de défense et des sécurités et
vous avez déjà mentionné quelques
quelques chiffres l'Allemagne va
consacrer son milliard supplémentaire à
la défense dans le cadre du changement
des portes
[Musique]
le grand discours de la chose lors de
l'attaque russe le 27 le 27 février ça
c'était quand même une décision
importante une décision qui qui a changé
la dynamique en Allemagne d'une façon
fondamentale et qui a aussi abouti à
beaucoup de débats on a un ami sur la
question de armement
à mon avis ces moyens devraient
être utilisé dans le cadre d'une
coopération européenne commune en
matière d'armement
la décision sur la F35 m'a surpris et
évidemment aussi déçu la participation
nucléaire et certainement un argument
pourquoi la manière à choisir de
utiliser pas mal de ressources de ces
100 milliards sur les F-35 mais
pratiquement
il y avait aussi des raisons pratiques
sur la possibilité d'obtenir rapidement
un nouveau système d'armes la F35 était
prêt à
être acheté pour
on a pu l'acheter directement
mais ceci ne devrait pas être
une
ne donnez pas ralentir
les projets communs entre la France et
l'Allemagne sur
des systèmes
la coopération de l'autre et l'autonomie
européenne signifie que l'Allemagne
devrait être prête à coordonner
davantage de telles décisions avec ses
partenaires je souhaite que le chantier
allemand face preuve d'encore plus de
leadership et de volonté sur ces ce
sujet mais il faut aussi que la France
soit prête à surmonter sa vieille image
coulisse et à pénis européenne
[Musique]
il est clair qu'il est inextable que
l'Europe continue à dépendre des
États-Unis pour cette sécurité il faut
donc travailler ensemble et cela doit
cela signifie que au niveau de l'Union
européenne et pas au niveau national
il faudra
s'organiser pour une industrie affective
armement européenne les actions
nationales isolées sont sont in
effectifs et coûteuses
deuxième grand thème
le thème de l'énergie
vous l'avez déjà mentionné évidemment
c'est aussi un grand sujet avec beaucoup
de divergences entre la France et
l'Allemagne un sujet c'est la question
du gaz et la question du nucléaire
encore une fois je suis là je suis un
académique et je dois je dois dire le
débat sur les nucléaires en Allemagne et
assez biologique même actuellement la
question de prolongement du
fonctionnement des
des centres d'énergie nucléaires pendant
quelques mois a été un super grand débat
idéologique en Allemagne et une décision
a été prise de prolonger
c'est ces centres nucléaires pendant
quelques mois ce qui est trop court à
mon avis on aurait on aurait dû
prolonger
le fonctionnement des décès centre
nucléaire pour quelques années mais ça
n'a pas été possible
domestiquement
mais il faut aussi dire que les
nucléaires en Allemagne ne résoudra pas
le problème de la pénurie d'énergie à
terme l'Allemagne a besoin de gaz
les centres nucléaires sont simplement
insuffisants pour fournir l'énergie
nécessaire donc l'Allemagne a besoin de
du gaz et le gouvernement a pu obtenir
un remplacement
presque complet du
des livraisons russes donc la Russie
ne fournit plus de gaz en Allemagne et
par contre c'est la Norvège et le gas
liquide qui ont
lnj qui ont remplacé pas mal de pas mal
de pas mal du gaz européen
du gastrus le classement le plafonnement
des prix
c'est un débat qui est très difficile
mais à mon avis un placement rigide des
prix rendra plus difficile l'achat de
gaz en quantité suffisante et suffisante
peut-être la grande exception ou on
pourrait vraiment négocier
si on travaille ensemble sur le prix de
gaz c'est c'est avec avec la Norvège qui
fournit pas mal de notre gaz et la
Norvège
n'a pas ne peut pas facilement
[Musique]
exporter tout ce Gasque qui est
actuellement livré en Europe par des
exportations à des pays tiers car il
faut des capacités LNG qui que la
Norvège n'a pas donc il y a une marche
de manœuvre sur sur le prix de gaz
avec la Norvège
la bonne nouvelle et actuellement entre
temps les prix se sont stabilisés en
Europe donc on a on a plus une situation
comme c'était il y a quelques il y a
quelques mois
et on a même eu des moments où le prix a
été négatif car
les stockages a été plein et la
consommation était assez basse
mais encore une fois
mettre une un plafond
déterministique ou un placement très
rigide sur les prix
d'achat
si ça va ou au détriment
des importations ça serait quand même un
grand problème pour pour obtenir une
quantité suffisante
ceci ne veut pas dire que qu'on ne peut
pas négocier sur des solutions
pour diminuer la volatilité des prix là
je crois on fait les
négociations en Europe font du progrès
mais
un plafond de prix
sur tous les importations de
peu avoir des conséquences négatives sur
la quantité obtenue
troisième point rapidement et il est
assez lié à la question du gaz
c'est c'est le paquet de 200 milliards
en Allemagne et qui a été beaucoup
critiqué en Europe et
en partie encore une fois en partie
cette critique a été justifiée mais
seulement en partie
la la le gouvernement allemand
a certainement très très mal communiqué
sur sur ce sujet
[Musique]
tout d'abord il faut constater que
la somme de 200 milliards a été obtenu
où on veut le gouvernement veut obtenir
cette somme pendant cette année pour
des raisons
[Musique]
pour des raisons statistiques ils ont
pas statistiques mais
comptable pour des raisons comptables
pour éviter de
d'aller sur les marchés en grande
quantité l'année prochaine parce que
l'année prochaine
le gouvernement allemand veut respecter
sa règle de
dette
break je sais plus comment comment dire
français pour pour réduire la quantité
de dettes donc c'est plutôt un truc
comptable que
que les 200 milliards ne sont pas
utilisés cette année mais sont utilisés
pendant plusieurs années donc c'est pas
c'est pas une somme utilisée dans une
année mais une somme pour plusieurs
années à cause des
raisons compta donc ça ça a été mal
communiqué
une partie de cette somme et aussi
utilisée pour
unibert donc c'est un bel hôte un
support pour une compagnie d'énergie
mais malgré tout c'est quand même un
grand paquet il faut l'avouer il faut
être clair là-dessus et c'est un grand
parquet et ça peut créer des distorsions
de le marché unique en Europe
ce qui est le plus important là-dessus
c'est de savoir comment l'argent va être
dépensé pour améliorer la situation des
chômas des
ménages et des entreprises on en
Allemagne
il faut être très clair que
ça ça doit pas être ça devrait pas être
une subvention pour
abaissir abaisser le prix de gaz on veut
pas
encourager la consommation du gaz au
contraire
et il faut mettre une place un mécanisme
pour réduire la consommation du gaz
donc l'Allemagne doit vier à ce que les
dépenses supplémentaires entraînent des
économies d'énergie et pas le contraire
il y a une commission d'expert la
proposition de la Commission du gaz
a été très clair là-dessus et très ciblé
donc ils ont donné des institutions pour
faire des économies et pas pour
encourager la consommation du gaz donc
ça c'est quand même important pour le
marché unique d'énergie et va aider
d'autres pays s'il a une manière
consomme moins et l'Allemagne consomme
quand même 20% moins de gaz qu'il y a un
qu'il y a une année mais il faut encore
encourager encore plus des économies
donc ça c'était très clair dans une
commission des experts c'est la
Commission du gaz des gaz commercial
mais actuellement il y a un grand débat
politique là-dessus et il est important
que la politique n'assouplisse pas trop
les choses il faut pas subventionner les
prix à la baisse car
alors le chat se mordonne la queue si on
essaye de
subventionner les prix à la baisse la
consommation va augmenter et ça va
augmenter le prix de nouveau donc ça il
faut il faut quand même éviter et
j'espère vraiment que ces discussions
politiques
ne vont pas assouplir cette
discussion donc ça c'est ça ce sont les
grands les grands thèmes que vous avez
déjà mentionnés j'ai essayé de vous
expliquer un peu le débat allemand
et de d'être assez clair sur le fait que
j'aimerais bien voir plus
une perspective européenne dans le débat
allemand là-dessus
c'est certainement mon rôle en tant que
chercheur à Berlin de mettre un accent
sur
les questions européennes dans le débat
dans les débats allemands mais il faut
aussi dire que c'est la guerre c'est
quand même un choc un bouleversement
très très significatif et on voit dans
tous les pays en Europe à mon avis
le système politique
régale plus à l'intérieur
c'est
les citoyens c'est les électeurs
domestiques qui devient plus important
dans une situation de stress avec
beaucoup d'inflation avec une hausse des
prix d'énergie
une insécurité par rapport à la
situation de la guerre on voit partout
que les politiciens regardent un peu
chez soi et évidemment ça c'est le grand
danger c'est le grand danger pour notre
autonomie stratégique c'est un grand
danger pour notre capacité de gagner
cette guerre c'est une un grand un grand
défi
pour la sécurité européenne et elle faut
travailler à tous ensemble pour remettre
un accent sur le fait que seulement si
les pays européennes travaillent
ensemble
seulement dans ce cas on peut
rester
autonome et garder une autonomie
stratégie et renforcer notre notre
stratégie autonomique stratégie
autrement merci beaucoup
merci merci Monsieur le Directeur donc
finalement la question que je vous ai
posé alors vous y avez répondu en partie
et je comprends que que vous
souhaitiez rester en tout cas avec un
regard neutre plus académique
les propos que je vous ai tenu là que
vous avez considéré comme dur je les ai
tenues hier en séance plénière enfin en
question d'actualité au Gouvernement
hier
dans l'hémicycle parce que finalement la
question de fin que je vous posais je la
pose toujours c'est est-ce que les
stratégies mises en place par
l'Allemagne aujourd'hui sont des
stratégies allemandes ou des stratégies
européennes et la réponse
malheureusement je pense vous nous
l'apportez avec les éléments
complémentaires que vous nous donnez on
est sur des stratégies purement
allemandes et donc
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président bonjour et
merci Monsieur Wolf pour votre vos
explications et pour aller dans le sens
du président Rapin effectivement nous
savons très bien qu'il faut une Europe
forte et moi j'ai toujours entendu dire
que si nous voulons une Europe forte il
faut un couple franco-allemand fort
aujourd'hui on a plutôt que d'entendre
parler de couple franco-allemand on
entend plus parler des relations
franco-allemandes qui sont tendus donc
c'est un peu décevant dans ce sens là et
je pense que effectivement il faut que
nous travaillons ensemble pour pouvoir
répondre à ces différentes défis qui
nous ont été posées par cette guerre et
dans ces défis il y a effectivement les
prix de l'énergie et hier nous avons
appris que les prix de l'énergie allait
être bloquée en Allemagne à partir du
1er janvier 2023 que ce soit le prix de
gaz ou et de l'électricité les deux donc
pour lutter contre l'inflation qui
dépasse dans votre pays aujourd'hui
après les éléments qui dépasseraient 10%
et ce bouclier tarifaire avait été
promis par les chancelier Olaf scholls
en septembre
mais ce cette décision à nouvelle fois
irrite plusieurs partenaires européens
de l'Allemagne qui à nouveau lui
reproche de faire cavalier seul donc
comment voyez-vous
cette possibilité de bloquer les prix de
l'énergie et surtout comment le financer
merci Didier marie puis Daniel Gremillet
merci président merci Monsieur Wolf
on assiste à une remise en cause totale
de la politique
de l'Allemagne
à l'égard de son grand voisin russe
suite effectivement à l'invasion de
l'Ukraine et on passe donc du noces de
politique
à qui parenté à un dialogue constructif
à
l'affirmation
que cette fameuse maison commune
européenne
ne pourra pas voir le jour et ça se
traduit vous l'avez dit par une
politique de sevrage de gaz russe par
une politique de réarmement par un
renforcement des relations
transatlantiques qui se traduisent par
l'achat de matériel militaire américain
mais aussi par une modification de
l'approche de l'Allemagne à l'égard de
l'élargissement de l'Union européenne en
particulier à l'égard de l'Ukraine la
Moldavie de la Géorgie sur lesquels
l'Allemagne était plutôt réticente et
aujourd'hui
très favorable moi j'aurais trois
questions à vous poser
la première on a bien entendu les propos
du change du chancelier scholls mais
qu'en est-il des positions au sein de la
coalition qu'en est-il de la position de
la Cedeo et plus largement
se revirement
majeur de la relation de l'Allemagne
avec son environnement immédiat est-il
soutenu par l'opinion publique ou y
a-t-il des réticences et des résistances
sachant qu'on a entendu ici là des
appels à la négociation à la fin de la
guerre et
pour certaines populations notamment de
la de l'Est
des difficultés à assumer ce revirement
deuxième question
quel est selon vous la position de
l'Allemagne à l'égard de la communauté
politique européenne qui est promue par
le président français
à laquelle l'Allemagne dans un premier
temps assemblé à voir
une attitude plutôt réservée et donc en
est-il aujourd'hui et puis enfin
troisième élément ça a été évoqué par le
président tout à l'heure dans son propos
on s'inquiète de la stratégie
commerciale à l'égard de la Chine on
sait que la Chine et le premier
partenaire enfin en dehors de l'Union
Européenne de l'Allemagne et inversement
que les relations sont nécessairement
importante
mais ce cavalier seul peut sembler
étrange aux tu restes de l'Union
européenne donc si vous avez un
sentiment là dessus
là serait intéressant de vous entendre
merci
merci Daniel encore le temps parce que
je sais qu'il intervient en DG en séance
oui merci Président Monsieur le
Directeur chers collègue
ma question va être simple effectivement
on a vu un accord dans l'immédiat parce
qu'il y avait urgence entre la France et
l'Allemagne sur je te donne du gaz tu me
donnes des garanties de fournitures
d'électricité
mais on ne voit pas du tout de stratégie
énergétique au niveau communautaire et
surtout entre l'Allemagne et la France
la France qui fait le choix de nucléaire
qui fait le choix d'une énergie
décarbonée pour atteindre des objectifs
de 2050 et on voit bien que la
compétition est complètement ouverte
entre les deux pays et que l'enjeu
énergétique sera déterminant sur le
développement industriel dans nos deux
pays au niveau communautaire bien sûr
mais entre l'Allemagne et la France et
que les choix qui sont faits aujourd'hui
si je parle de l'hydrogène la France
fait plutôt le choix de produire
l'hydrogène sur son territoire et
l'Allemagne plutôt d'importer
l'hydrogène donc on voit bien que les
choix à la fois nucléaires à la fois du
futur sur l'hydrogène sont complètement
différentes et je voudrais m'excuser
Monsieur le Directeur auprès de vous
parce qu'effectivement comme on l'a dit
le Président je il y a un texte tout de
suite en séance ou au Sénas je dois
intervenir en DG justement sur les les
puisqu'il y a nous voulons accélérer les
processus d'implantation de NR sur nos
territoires avec tous mes excuses mais
c'est le président de mes collègues me
diront m'importeront votre réponse merci
à vous
merci Daniel oui vas-y vas-y vas-y ne
sois pas en retard Monsieur le Directeur
si vous voulez apporter des précisions
ce qui vous a été demandé
un grand merci pour toutes ces questions
très pertinentes et c'est quand même des
questions très difficiles en fait à
répondre mais je vais je vais l'essayer
quand même
commençons par les questions de
l'énergie et les prix et la grande
stratégie à court terme
on n'a pas encore pris l'Allemagne il
n'a pas encore pris une décision sur
exactement comment changer
et aider les
gainages et les entreprises
il y avait une commission de prix de de
gaz une commission indépendante qui
incluait les académiques les experts
mais aussi les représentants de la
politique et des travailleurs les
représentants de travailleurs et cette
commission a mis un grand accent sur
les deux
choses les plus importantes à la fois
aider les ménages et des entreprises
mais au même temps encouragé des
économies de la consommation
et ce qu'ils ont proposé c'est au lieu
de subventionner le prix ils ont proposé
de
donner une somme fixe
en décembre et à partir du mois de mars
de
subventionner le premier 80% de la
consommation de l'année dernière donc
c'est à dire si on consomme à partir de
mars si on consomme 80% de ce qu'on a
consommé en 2020
[Musique]
on a on paye un prix diminué sur cette
consommation
mais chaque megavat qu'on consomme de
plus et pénaliser d'une façon très
importante
donc c'est un mécanisme qui encourage à
une réduction de la consommation
par 20%
donc ça c'est quand même
un mécanisme qui devrait
réduire la consommation à un monde d'une
façon substantielle
[Musique]
si on regarde les chiffres actuels les
ménages ainsi que l'industrie allemande
consomme beaucoup moins que l'année
dernière et c'est en réaction d'une prix
d'un prix élevé donc c'est à dire là on
a quand même utilisé l'Allemagne à
utiliser l'instrument du prix la semaine
du marché pour
forcer un changement de la consommation
allemande qui est ce qui est nécessaire
car
car les livraisons ne autrement ne
seront pas suffisantes et ce qui ce qui
en plus
un grand soulagement pour le marché
européen du gaz car l'Allemagne est
consomme consommé comme comme l'année
dernière ça faisait quand même beaucoup
sur
sur le marché unique du gaz et comme ça
et au moins il y a des incitations il y
a une consommation de moi d'un grand
consommateur l'Allemagne et donc ça ça
aide à réduire les prix dans d'autres
d'autres parts de l'Europe donc ça c'est
quand même il y a c'était un grand thème
et c'est une grande
on a on a vu une très très grande
un très grand ajustement dans
l'industrie
consommation et déjà à la baisse par
rapport
au moyen des années dernière
à peu près 20% mais la création la
valeur ajoutée n'a pas baissé ou presque
pas et donc et ça c'était le grand débat
de cette année
en Allemagne beaucoup des industriels
ont dit si on réduit la consommation de
l'énergie on va réduire
la valeur ajoutée d'une façon très
significative et ça c'était la peur
politique mais la peur politique
n'a été pas correct en fait on a on a pu
substituer
et réduire la consommation sans que la
production soit négativement affectée de
toute façon pas de pas beaucoup
donc ça ça c'était le premier succès
actuellement
le
système politique c'est-à-dire le
Parlement discute en détail comment
adapter les
propositions de cette commission
d'experts de gaz
mais je crois pas qu'ils ont pris qu'ils
ont pris une décision claire
[Musique]
par rapport à l'année prochaine la
discussion maintenant est-ce qu'on va
introduire ce système à partir du mois
de février au lieu de mois de mars
mais je crois le point principal c'est
tout le monde a compris il faut réduire
les incitations de à consommer il faut
pas subventionner le prix ça c'est très
important très important
si on parle de la stratégie à moyen
terme à moyen terme
il me semble que
l'Allemagne
voit
une transformation
pour des énergies renouvelables
en tant que
défi et en tant que but principal de la
transition écologique dans les années
dans les années prochaines
pas tout le monde le voit comme ça mais
je crois là il y a quand même en
consensus de mettre en place
le
c'est-à-dire l'approche européenne et
réduire la consommation des énergies
fossiles et augmenter le rôle du
renouvelable
le nucléaire ne joue aucun rôle un moyen
long terme en Allemagne et ça c'était
une décision prise par déjà par
de la mer que l'après Fukushima mais
c'est une décision qui est quand même
partager
donc en partie de la société allemande
c'est-à-dire un moyen long terme ça sera
renouvelable et
le hydrogène vert
joue un rôle important et vous avez tout
à fait raison que l'hydrogène vers
le plan à Mons et de faire des
implantations
pour
ce hydrogène vers car on a conclu comme
qu'on pourrait pas produire suffisamment
de l'énergie
renouvelable en Allemagne
pour produire ce hydrogène vert donc
c'est-à-dire il nous faut des
importations pour l'énergie de cette
énergie donc là c'est ça la discussion à
peu près
mais je crois vraiment toute cette
discussion se joue dans le cadre du
yorking
c'est pas c'est pas cette transition est
pensée dans un contexte
et pour le l'hydrogène vert par exemple
c'est pas des projets national et
donc c'est à dire des projets de
subvention à l'échelle européen
qui sont approuvés par la Commission
européenne donc ça c'est la stratégie
sur moyen terme de l'énergie
puis vous avez
puis le sujet hausse politique
Ukraine
et comité communauté politique européen
donc par rapport à la hausse politique
je crois que maintenant
il y a une discussion très active
sur les échecs de la politique
[Musique]
et beaucoup des
politiciens le système politique
accepte que le rapprochement entre
l'Allemagne et la Russie et la façon
comment ça a été faite ces dernières
années
a été une grande erreur et
pas tout le monde est convaincu mais je
vois quand même l'opposition les verres
les libéraux et des parties
significatifs des sociaux-démocrates
sont convaincus que le rapprochement à
la Russie a été une grande erreur et on
a compris que la sécurité de notre
continent
peut seulement être garanti contre la
Russie avec la Russie donc ça c'est ça
c'est quand même le grand changement
qui a été pris qui a
qui s'est déroulé cette année en
Allemagne un grand changement
et il y a une discussion assez vive sur
les erreurs de l'époque de l'époque
mercure là-dessus donc donc ça ça c'est
un grand changement par rapport à
l'Ukraine
est-ce que la population veut voir
l'Ukraine dans l'Union européenne très
prochainement je n'y crois pas
tout d'abord
l'Ukraine est en guerre tout d'abord il
faut assurer que l'Ukraine gagne cette
guerre il me semble c'est d'une
importance centrale pour l'Allemagne et
pour la France
et
j'aimerais bien voir encore plus
d'accent sur cette question
parce que si s'il y a un conflit
permanent en
Ukraine ça va plaisir sur
[Musique]
sur toute l'Union européenne donc il y a
à mon avis il faut il faut vraiment
[Musique]
donner plus de support à l'Ukraine et
et c'est le chancelier qui qui ne fait
pas assez mais le président Macron aussi
il ne fait pas assez là-dessus et ça
c'est le sujet principal si on si on ne
parle pas de ce sujet
toute la discussion sur
[Musique]
la question du de l'Ukraine et l'Ukraine
dans l'Union européenne est une
discussion théorique donc d'abord
l'Ukraine doit gagner cette guerre
si elle gagne ça va prendre
beaucoup de beaucoup des années pour
reconstruire l'Ukraine et pour permettre
à l'Ukraine de
compléter tous les chapitres
d'accession à l'Union européenne donc
c'est-à-dire l'État de droit la
corruption toutes ces sujets sont des
sujets très très importants et je crois
les publics allemands voient beaucoup
voir comme le défi
de corruption le défi de financement de
cette convergence qui devrait être
nécessaire qui est nécessaire avant que
l'Ukraine puisse
devenir un membre de l'Union européenne
donc ça c'est quand même un trajet un
trajet très très long devant nous
communiquer politique européenne
de mon point de vue
actuellement c'est plutôt un ratio
rassemblement
ils ont assez informel
[Musique]
qui
et un grand signal
qu'on est unique contre la Russie donc
on a quand même 40 je sais plus 45
chef d'État qui était qui était
à la première réunion
et
première réunion à Prague et qui ont
quand même
donné une
un signal fort
à la Russie parce que la Russie n'était
pas là
[Musique]
est-ce que cette communauté peut prendre
des décisions très concrètes
il me semble que c'est assez difficile
quand même parce que sur des questions
de des sanctions par exemple ou des
sexes des questions d'énergie
des questions de
sécurité et on a quand même des
mécanismes au sein de l'Union européenne
et on veut pas une concurrence entre
[Musique]
donc finalement la Chine
j'ai publié ce lundi un article dans Le
finance là-dessus
et
ils ont
c'est je crois pas que ça
s'amuse à Pékin
et vient un bon moment donc c'est trop
tôt et
[Musique]
il y va
et ce qui est important c'est quand même
de transporter et prendre des bons
messages et les trois messages qui sont
à mon avis centrales c'est sécurité
européenne c'est
la priorité première allemande et
européenne
c'est à dire si la Chine si la Chine
commence à
aider la rue si d'une façon beaucoup
plus significative qu'actuellement par
exemple en livrer en livraison avec des
livraisons d'armes
[Musique]
ça devrait avoir des conséquences
immédiates pour la relation Europe
Chine à une relation économique
on peut pas accepter que la Chine est la
Russie ça c'est le premier message qui
devrait livrer deuxième message
toutes les questions
de commerce et investissement sont des
questions à l'échelle de l'Union
européenne c'est l'Union européenne qui
est responsable pour le commerce et pour
les investissements et
[Musique]
l'Allemagne ne
accepter
une politique chinoise
qui essayent de diviser l'Union
européenne par exemple comme la Chine
l'a fait avec une cohérence une équation
économique contre contre la Lituanie
c'est inacceptable il faut il faut
travailler ensemble c'est l'Union
européenne qui est
qui négocie sur le commerce et les
investissements avec la Chine
troisième message
[Musique]
c'est aux entreprises les entreprises
devraient être prêt
à une excellation d'une détention
géopolitique entre les États-Unis et la
Chine et entre l'Europe et la Chine donc
c'est-à-dire on peut faire du commerce
avec la Chine mais il faut être prêt en
tant que entreprise que
cette cette commerce s'arrête d'une
façon assez rapide s'il y a une
musculation des tensions donc c'est
quand même une veste management
il faut gérer ce risque géostratégique
au niveau au sein des entreprises et ça
c'est un message qui devrait être très
important
donc j'espère que le chantier a allume
mon article dans Le dans le fanage mais
à mon avis c'est des messages centralité
européenne gérer la confrontation
géostratégique et
la sécurité européenne est une priorité
par rapport à la Chine un grand merci
merci Monsieur le Directeur juste un
petit point pour préciser avant de
terminer vous nous avez fait part et
j'ai compris dans votre discours que
l'opinion allemande n'était pas
forcément favorable dans les conditions
actuelles à une intégration de l'Ukraine
à l'Union européenne c'est c'est cela en
fait parce que ça on le perçoit pas de
chez nous moi je vous avoue il y a une
forme d'angélisme sur la question
effectivement il fallait envoyer des
signes à l'Ukraine mais on n'avait pas
forcément la vision on avait la vision
des stratèges et des diplomates vous
n'avez pas forcément la vision des états
et là globalement vous nous dites que
l'opinion est pas tellement favorable
non mais je crois l'opinion publique
c'est quand même
tout d'abord le public ne réfléchit pas
pas beaucoup aussi sur la question sur
cette question mais vous avez le droit
de le dire
mais mais
si on démonte
[Musique]
on voit rapidement dans la population
que ça va être coûteuse ça va ça coûte
quelque chose et
c'est pourquoi cette convergence c'est
quand un processus de convergence qui
doit
prendre qui devrait être faite avant que
l'Ukraine peut être un membre de l'Union
européenne on peut pas accepter l'Union
européenne
un pays
en guerre même si la guerre s'arrête un
pays très pauvre au sein de l'Union
européenne avec beaucoup de problèmes de
gouvernance et des corruption tout
d'abord il faut toute cette convergence
puis après on parle
qu'il devienne membres donc tant que ça
là le public est assez clair
[Musique]
très bien écoutez je vous remercie je
vous remercie beaucoup de cette échange
on voit qu'on est quand même en phase
sur certains aspects là votre votre
vision
berlinoise alors je sais pas si elle
nous conforte en tout cas
le sentiment qu'on avait après vous
entendre ce confirme et il est important
qu'on puisse inverser les tendances et
inverser la boussole pour pour essayer
de retrouver cette unité cette
solidarité européenne et finalement ce
pourquoi l'Europe a été faite
si j'ai été dur hier je suppose que vous
n'êtes pas sans avoir lu cette fameuse
tribune dans les échos de Jacques Attali
qui qui utilise le mot guerre entre la
France et l'Allemagne c'est vraiment
très dur mais on le voit au niveau
stratégique que les orientations sont
aujourd'hui complètement différentes
et je crois qu'il est il est temps pour
nous pour nos gouvernants de redresser
la barre si on veut maintenir l'union
d'une Europe qui est aujourd'hui
fortement fragilisée
merci en tout cas
un grand merci à vous